homelessness drug use spiraling out of
control and public view
it has become so bad that one four-star
hotel
has been turned into a homeless shelter
for drug addicts
and according to a report from the new
york post the section of midtown
manhattan
also happening in the upper east side
the prestigious upper east side
now filled with attic shooting up heroin
and broad daylight and full public view
it's so bad that discarded needles are
lining the streets
which brings us to tonight's hannity
special investigation we sent our own
2020 correspondent lawrence jones
to new york today to find out exactly
what is going on
and what he found should shock the
conscience but remember
a preview of coming attractions if
biden's america became a reality in 97
days
here with more fox news correspondent
2020 correspondent investigative
reporter lawrence jones
lawrence you learned a lot today
yeah good evening sean as you know we
have been covering american cities and
crisis and these cities
happen to be run by democratic mayors
and new york city isn't any different
residents are furious
about individuals openly shooting up
drugs with needles and they placed the
blame squarely with their mayor
bill de blasio take a look
so how long have they been around here
three months they've been here
since the shutdown they've been here
every single day and they just you shoot
up and open
shoot up and you have if we smoke a
cigarette
30 people attack us what do the leaders
do as a result of that nobody
nothing and you say it's not that bad
because you come from san francisco
yeah i mean by comparison it's it's you
know i don't i don't
even see it anymore because i'm just i'm
kind of i'm kind of um
i'm kind of numb to the whole to the
whole thing seeing people shooting up
what do you think about
new york being compared to san francisco
and skid row
it's getting there it's getting there
absolutely what do you blame for all of
this
um the mayor the mayor de blasio he's
responsible
absolutely have you ever seen new
if only that was bad enough we saw the
caps of the needles everywhere they
decided to clean it up today
after the new york post report but now
they're putting
homeless individuals in four stars
hotels but the only thing is
they didn't tell the residents that are
currently staying in those communities
they aren't happy take a look
they moved the homeless population some
of the homeless population across the
street here
are you concerned i'm a bit concerned
especially as a woman at night
because i work at night and i come home
late and just during the day i just saw
one guy
help another totally out of it guy
across the street
he must have been drugged the whole
dynamics of the community have changed
do you support them doing this in your
community
not really do you believe that the mayor
made a bad move by now
absolutely it's being done because
they're trying to get them out of
congregate settings
where the covet of thing can spread
i mean you have to put them somewhere
you have to put them with individual
rooms
and i think if it's very well
coordinated and supervised
it can work i've been living here since
the early 80s and
i've seen so many drug deals go down
i don't want i don't want those days to
come back
sean as you can see in the video these
local businesses have to hire
private security to protect their
patrons from the homeless people that
are
strung out on drugs now the people
wanted to make it very clear they are
not
anti-getting homeless help they wanted
to be consulted and is the four-star
hotel really the place to put them back
to you sean
and you saw people literally shooting up
by the way we're not talking about the
what we know to be say more crime-ridden
areas in new york we're talking about
midtown
the quote expensive upper east side of
new york
yeah we're talking about the expensive
side china we not only saw them shooting
up but we also saw them
prepping their their drugs right in this
area as well
and of course when i talk to residents
and say you know why
why aren't the police enforcing the laws
that are on the book
they blame the mayor for the defund the
police
methods that he had disbanding the
anti-crime unit saying that they feel
like the officers
that they used to see on a day-to-day
basis feel like their hands are tied
and they don't want to lose their jobs
or their livelihood
and didn't you also see people have seen
pictures of defecation
not unlike what you saw in san francisco
people urinating defecating in the
streets
yeah we saw that shine we actually
talked to one person that's not a new
york resident
that used to be in san francisco and he
said he almost feels
numb to it because he's already
experienced this before
all right lawrence jones great reporting
as always thank you